et patron d' angie d'edf et de total
energy appelle les français à réduire
immédiatement leur consommation de
pétrole de gaz d'électricité
l'impression peut-être que vous êtes une
première ministre en sursis
écoutez moi je suis pas en train de
poser ce genre de questions je peux vous
dire que moi je suis à l'action une
nécessité selon eux pour éviter une
pénurie d'énergie l'hiver prochain car
avec la guerre le gaz russe vient à
manquer et les importations notamment
depuis d'autres pays ne le compensent
pas totalement hier soir le président
fait taire les rumeurs en annonçant la
première ministre a ma confiance pour
mener l'action du gouvernement dans la
durée pour notre pays il n'y a pas que
la note de la guerre en ukraine il y
avait déjà une hausse des prix de
l'énergie très importante on avait vu à
l'automne dernier qui avait amené les
mesures de boucliers tarifaire ou de
chèques d'inflation en france et dans
d'autres pays blessant s'est amplifiée
il faut être très clair et très
transparent et ça va durer ça va durer
l'inflation elle est inscrite maintenant
dans la durée donc il faut des réponses
dans la durée va pas falloir seulement
des primes et des chèques ou non mais et
bein euh c'est kunlé vous et des
cheminées gironde à un gouvernement j'ai
l'impression moi d'avoir avec emmanuel
macron un chef de rayon chez carrefour
quoi faute de majorité absolue à
l'assemblée emmanuel macron veut faire
preuve d'ouverture mais avec des limites
ce sera des communistes aux élèves les
français ont accordé une légitimité au
député reynès et elle est fille mais ces
formations ne s'inscrivent pas comme des
partis de gouvernement pas de son
gouvernement ça c'est clair et
d'ailleurs nous lui avons dit ça
n'aurait aucun sens enfin monsieur macro
un bilan il a un projet sur lequel il
n'en rabat pas malgré la défaite
cuisante qui vient de prendre aux
élections législatives tout ce qui ira
dans le sens de mesures fortes pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français nous le
soutiendrons nous voulons que ça avance
et que cela avance vite et fort que je
rassure monsieur macron le jour où les
français nous donneront la majorité il
verra que le rassemblement national est
un parti de gouvernement
ça me dérange pas de ne pas être un
parti de gouvernement avec emmanuel
macron il n'ya pas il y aura pas de
macron maintenant si on regarde
l'interview du président de la
république hier le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que jupiter patauge il sait
plus par où s'en sortir je pense que ça
n'est pas possible l'union nationale
je ne vois pas des forces politiques
élue dans l'opposition
entrée dans la majorité parce qu'ils
auraient le sentiment est d'ailleurs ce
serait fondé de se renier je fais une
différence j'insiste beaucoup sur ce
point fondamental entre la france en
soumises et le rassemblement national je
crois qu'ils n'ont pas le même rapport à
la société à la haine à la division et
je les dis qui est le plus haineux qui
est le moins haineux dans l'isère et moi
je vais toujours dit cette nomination de
pap ndiaye
emmanuel un croûton la pensée comme un
coup dégager des majorités en s'alliant
au rassemblement national alors que
plusieurs membres du gouvernement
semblait ouvert à cette idée
le nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale pap ndiaye exclu
catégoriquement cette éventualité
quelles qu'en soient les circonstances
j'adresse un clin d'oeil à l'électorat
de la france
insoumise et ça n'a pas tout à fait
fonctionner aux etats unis une
régression historique le droit à
l'avortement menacé par une décision de
la cour suprême deuxième jour de
manifestations pour les partisans du
droit à l'avortement voyez ici à
washington où plusieurs centaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées devant la
cour suprême
l'incroyable histoire du spécialiste du
400 m haies où ils frida piot il a été
sacré champion de france hier à caen
mais dans des conditions rocambolesques
juste avant la course sur le stade
d'échauffement il a été frappé par un
homme qu'il a blessé à l'oeil gauche
avant d'être arrêté engagez vous mais
sans oeillères sans fanatisme
parce que là vous vous perdrez wilfried
hapiot s'est donc présenté sur la ligne
de départ avec un bandeau noir ce qui
n'a pas empêché de gagner avoir de
l'espoir ce n'est pas être optimiste
parce que l'espoir c'est du possible ce
n'est jamais du certains